one of the reasons that it is crucial
that everybody just stay home is that
many people have the virus but have no
symptoms or almost no symptoms and what
are sometimes called asymptomatic or
sometimes maybe more accurately
subclinical cases and the question has
been to what degree is this a thing
we've heard numbers thrown out that
suggests anywhere from as little as five
or ten percent of the population that's
infected all the way up to 50 percent
may be asymptomatic or at least
subclinical and Iceland has been testing
this pretty precisely with some large
numbers of tests which they can do
thanks to their small population
Iceland's total population is under
400,000 people total and the latest
results from a study of 9,000 people in
Iceland is that as many as half of those
infected have no idea because they have
no symptoms noticeable enough for them
to perceive those so what Iceland did is
Iceland did a test of about five has so
far tested about five percent of its
population just pretty broad testing
that's about 18,000 tests and then
there's been a separate testing protocol
which has tested 9,000 people who chose
to participate fewer than 1% of the
tests came back positive meaning that
the the percentage of the population in
fact it is believed to be under 1% but
half of the positive tests were people
who said I never had any symptoms
I felt fine the entire time and yet they
if they're not home which many in
Iceland are not because Iceland actually
has not done the stay at home part very
seriously you are out spreading the
disease if you are out and about this is
why everybody's got to stay home the
asymptomatic spread appears to be
absolutely huge now understand that even
though this this 9,000 person test was
randomized it is made up of people who
are choosing to get tested and that
could impact the results in some way but
imagine it's not 50% and it's 20% or 15%
a 15% of the cases that are out there
are asymptomatic and people don't know
it that's why it's
important to stay home regardless of how
you feel regardless of your age or
anything else we're working together
we're trying to get past this and this
result also reinforces the eventual
importance of having a simple at-home
antibody test which could answer the
question did I ever have coronavirus now
the FDA did yesterday approved the first
antibody test the serology tests it is a
blood test but it's not a pinprick test
it's a vein test you would once this
gets rolled out you would have to go
into a lab to have the test done how
many of those tests were likely to do
under that protocol to test the
population I don't really know but we
are going in the direction of being able
to test for antibodies which is a very
good thing often when people post to
social media and say you know I think I
might have had this a month ago a month
and a half ago whatever it's very
popular to shame those people and to say
stop being dramatic almost everybody who
has it has a fever and that's true of
symptomatic patients who have been
tested if you don't have symptoms you
obviously don't have a fever and when we
get eventually to the point where we can
start opening back up a little bit one
of the things that would be really
useful would be test people if you find
swathes of the population that have
antibodies and have had the disease and
are presumably immune those are people
that could get back to work earlier
while other groups may maintain physical
distancing for a longer period of time
it's early to be talking about that but
we need to start doing some antibody
testing of the population as soon as we
have a test that can be done in large
numbers and it can become part of the
eventual plan we're not there yet but
the eventual plan of getting some parts
of the population back to work when it
is deemed safe and appropriate by
medical professionals not by politicians
trying to win re-election in a few
months if you ever feel like you just
don't have enough time to read all the
books you want to read you have to check
out one of my favorite apps called
blinky splink ax stakes thousands of
popular nonfiction books and distills
each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from ten
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time of course
by the great Stephen Hawking this is a
book that I have been aware of for so
long and other things got in the way and
it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video